everybody has a plan until you get hit  in the face yeah I've used that in the  podcast yeah so  I really did feel that Lawrence from  what I've heard and from what I  understood about his his level of  preparedness for the boxing part  was in my head a favorite in the boxing  part so we know one thing about Lawrence  is he would never exaggerate the work he  puts in or his achievements or the trash  talking so he says he's worked very hard  there's no reason not to believe and I  mean  it's a good bit but I also like in this  particular case don't really feel like  he was  yeah I think he puts so much pressure on  himself by talking yeah [ __ ] before and  I do think he's actually been training  boxing for a while now yeah it's been  years like even before  this opportunity came his way so he's  yeah probably upset about how it went